happen so we're going to draft given
that basic formula the best match-ups to
come with the 17th game in an 18-week
season trivia question for peter king
who won the super bowl
the last time the nfl had an 18-week
regular season
the new england patriots
[Music]
18 week regular season no idea
1993 it was a year with two buys 16
regular season games two buys dallas
cowboys after starting owen two during
the emmett smith holdout managed to
defeat the buffalo bills for the second
straight year to win their second
straight championship with an 18-week
regular season i didn't like the two
buys plenty of people still want two
buys this time around 18 weeks will be
happening by virtue of 17 games all
right well
uh sometimes it helps
to win
the
the first pick sometimes it doesn't
today it does hello
chiefs packers hello patrick mahomes
aaron rodgers we missed it the last time
around because patrick mahomes was
injured we missed it in the super bowl
this year because the packers couldn't
close the deal at home against the tampa
bay buccaneers to qualify for the super
bowl we're going to get it this year
instantly that 17th game from that
category of possible 17th games comes
the best game of the year chiefs packers
peter
i mean that's so far number one that's
the best game in the league this coming
year
um
and so look there's no question that
that that's the best week 17 or game 17
game
i'm gonna take seattle in pittsburgh and
the reason why is because
i think that both teams
are on the precipice
you know
what's the future of both franchises and
what's the future of both franchise
quarterbacks
this will be without any question the
last time ben roethlisberger and russell
wilson play each other unless they meet
in the super bowl this season
so you know to me i like that matchup
and i like it happening
uh
i i hope it happens sort of late in the
season with a lot on the line
the last time those two teams played
it was the ben roethlisberger elbow went
out game week two in 2019 four years
before that it was the
ben roethlisberger tapped out with
concussion-like symptoms
a step that really helped push the
culture towards self-reporting and of
course way back when when russell wilson
probably was in high school the steelers
beat the seahawks to win super bowl 40.
so that is a good one another matchup
that has some history not by virtue of
the teams but by virtue of the
participants
tampa bay buccaneers indianapolis colts
tom brady the team that
instigated deflategate the team that
has always been one of the top rivals
for tom brady when he's with the new
england patriots the rivalry is back on
as chris ballard said when josh
mcdaniels jilted the colts a few years
ago that game otherwise if without tom
brady who cares buccaneers cults who
cares you throw tom brady into it and
that becomes a compelling game and we're
getting that game this year because
there's going to be a 17th game peter
i got a sneaky one for my next one and
that is kyler murray baker mayfield
arizona cleveland both teams
that should should win double digits in
2021. i love the game not just because
of the good old boys
texas high school quarterback matchup
i like it because or
i like it because there's so many
great aspects of this game you know jj
watt uh chasing around another young
fast quarterback number one and i you
know i also really like the fact that to
me this is one of the next steps for the
cleveland browns
the browns have to win games like this
to continue their advancement you know
2020 was a really fun year for the
cleveland browns in all ways they won a
playoff game they beat dreaded rival
pittsburgh in a playoff game but now
it's about taking that next step being
consistently good every week and beating
playoff contenders like arizona
and they were teammates in oklahoma and
here's how close kylo mary and baker
mayfield are when murray was making the
rounds at the super bowl before he
decided to play football over baseball
he was on set with us mayfield called
him three times
during the interview because at one
point kylo said baker keeps calling i
don't know whether it was
before we started or whenever but it was
clear to me that baker kept calling
kyler they are close they are tight and
they get to face each other this year
because of this 17th game cowboys
patriots i'll take cowboys patriots
anytime anyplace anywhere even though
the cowboys may not be very good the
patriots given the moves they've made
this year they will be better at least
we think they will be and that's always
a big game
uh because it's it's two of the biggest
national brands that the nfl has to
offer and it's a game that's happening
this year by virtue of the 17th game so
that's my next pick
you know my last one is this my last one
coming up or do we have one more round
it's up to you all right
my last one coming up is going to be new
orleans and tennessee
it's not going to be a sexy game for the
networks because it doesn't have big
markets or anything like that
but what is so cool about this game
is we are basically going to see
the next iteration of sean payton's new
orleans saints
whether whoever is going to play
quarterback and whatever they actually
look like
you know as an organization as a team
against a team that is out to redeem
itself
after a really shaky uh post season in
tennessee
so to me
i like the fact this is one of those
games that you would always point to and
say wow you know tennessee new orleans
this is not one of those great
traditional rivalries or anything like
that but i love the fact that jameis
winston
you know or taysom hill this is going to
be one more time proving himself against
another very good team
other games that stand out from me rams
ravens that was one of the coming out
parties for lamar jackson in 2019 when
he shredded the rams on a monday night
bill's in washington fitz magic used to
be the buffalo starting quarterback then
again he's played for so many teams he's
seen the bills enough times that he's
worked that out of his system one more
on my list that i see here all texans
panthers in the event that desean watson
would end up being traded to carolina
that becomes a game in the event uh is
significant and it is uh something
that's happening by virtue of the 17th
game by the way all those games peter
right afc hosted so it'll be nine home
games for the afc teams that's likely
and
it's likely it's not certain it's
likely but either way that's the only
way to avoid competitive imbalance
you've made that point a few weeks ago
it's going to be one of the other all
nfc
afc are all nfc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports